ladies and gentlemen here is Michael
Moore oh no please sit down this it's
not necessary Oh feels like the last
time I was on an asker stage except I um
was escorted off by Homeland Security I
know what you think and I'm up here i am
on an Oscar stage so you're about to get
a 10 minute rant on the fiscal cliff
well I'm sorry to disappoint you because
tonight I stand here as an academy gud
governor representing the documentary
branch by the way there is no fiscal
cliff here to present the first Oscar of
the evening to a true pioneer of this
art form that we all love so much I
realize you can't just toss out the word
pioneer loosely when you say film
pioneer you're talking about the Lumiere
brothers Thomas Edison DW Griffith
Charlie Chaplin Fritz Lang but tonight
we're honoring the man who with a group
of his friends invented nothing less
than the modern documentary I doubt that
there are many still alive whom we could
call a pioneer or an inventor of a genre
of film making but at 87 years old we
have one in our presence here tonight
before this man picked up a camera the
documentary catalog was made up of
wildlife movies where all the animals
were carefully neutered in the editing
room travel logs to exotic places like
Newfoundland and Baltimore government
propaganda films both for good to raise
money for war bonds and evil about a
will that fortunately never triumphed
there were the occasional great
documentaries back then and this Academy
honored each of them beginning in 1942
in the first best documentary
was presented but I think those of us
who grew up in the years after World War
two mostly remember documentaries as
films we had to watch in school scaring
the bejeebers out of us for smoking
marijuana or having sex before 30 or
teaching us how to duck and cover just
in case the soviets dropped an atomic
bomb on our school yard and then Along
Came da pennebaker with his compatriots
Richard leacock and Robert Drew and
later his partner the great filmmaker
Chris Hedges they decided that non
fiction films could be daring
provocative and dare I say it
entertaining to accomplish this
pennebaker and company did two very
simple things first they took the camera
off the tripod that's it in that one
moment when Pennebaker unscrewed the
camera from a stationary position the
world of all filmmaking changed
nonfiction and fiction pennebaker and
his friends invented the first sync
portable sync sound mechanism where the
16-millimeter camera could move and
sound would be in sync with it he
invented this apparatus back in the 50s
and it changed everything for filmmakers
regardless what kind of films they
wanted to make because sound could now
match the picture when the camera was
moving and when Pennebaker believed that
if the subject moved so should the
camera and I don't mean on a dolly I
mean pick the bloody thing up and go no
costumes no makeup no set design no
craft services no studio executives no
continuity and no script no script Penna
Baker's idea was that you would write
the movie after you shot it this was
anarchy madness I can't imagine how they
got the money to do this yes oh well um
you see we're going to come up with a
script right after we've shot the movie
the other thing that pennebaker and the
pioneers of cinema verite and direct
cinema did was to construct their movies
as movies not instructional film strips
not castor oil not boring but rather as
works of art of works of cinema movies
to be shown up on the big screen that's
where I first saw don't look back the
war room in monterey pop in a movie
theater what a radical idea well after
that the doors were flung open for
documentaries and Along Came Woodstock
and gimme shelter in hearts and minds
and showa and the thin blue line and
hoop dreams and on and on and on and on
thanks to you penny da pennebaker is
still making documentaries today now in
his 60th year as a filmmaker three of
his documentaries have been placed on
the Library of Congress national film
registry he has remarkably never won an
Oscar but all that is to change now I am
personally grateful penny for you
inspiring me and for inspiring the
countless others who have followed in
your very important and loving footsteps
please come up here and accept your much
deserved Oscar mr. da Pennebaker